well it's lovely to see you again at
collective a nice day what have people
been asking you most about the winner
who goes to dr. Heath I think they tend
to ask about why my incarnation of it
never came back before or will I come
back again if you wouldn't seems to want
to know you know when are we gonna see
you again and also I can't deny anything
because no one believes me you know you
made some more I mean you know I haven't
yes you're up we know you're lying
because you lied before about the other
thing so you can't win of course
obviously we saw you in the episode that
you did last year for the 50th
anniversary special and everyone loves
seeing you back there with your new
styling as well was great hold that
thought what the well-dressed except my
brother reckoned I look like Frodo so I
wanted to give him a dig know you like
did I didn't yeah I really liked him cuz
he looks like he's well he looks like
he's been in the wars literally which
was the whole point you know and he
looks like he could have a fight in it
that's important you know cuz he's like
that Liam you see the war doctor and
everything except apparently I've got
the sonic screwdriver the wrong way
round
yeah I like the little snake belt as
well very sort of 1970s alright I just
kind of say did you get him what he
looked like when he came back this time
none whatsoever
and that sounds probably how it should
be
I didn't I wanted to say when when we
did the original six greats like being
on Blue Peter and it's a mummy made over
here I had no say no I really would have
liked to say in it but that was a done
deal
you know I arrived there it was as with
the wig
because actors are often unless you've
really really really thought about it
you know in terms of you know the
character the story whatever you know
and and you know in almost my new detail
I don't think it's real it's not really
worth your chipping in with any idea
what designers are for you know they've
thought about it and then you know
they've got the whole design to think of
and not just in terms of the colors
whatever your the period or everything
no but I knew that it would be good and
clever and appropriate and so it was you
know it actually looked I thought better
than the first one but you know but it
like I said it it's sort of aged
appropriately unlike me so that's
another story entirely you say of course
people have been asking are you going to
come back but would you like to return
again as the doctor yeah would and if
obviously I couldn't even begin to think
about the circumstances you know we got
a new doctor now Capaldi's begun as
tenure he could be there for ten years
or more and quite right so Peter should
be given a clear run without any talk of
me or anybody else
you know that's that's not going to stop
the talk but he deserves a proper clear
run to get his feet under the tone I'll
probably never come back but if I did I
wouldn't mind I wouldn't mind at all if
it was just like the last time five
minutes every 15 years or something like
that comes in steals the glory doesn't
have to do anything hard work you know
comes on scores of penalty at the end no
I like what would you like to happen if
you could come back as the doctor
well respected but the story is that I
think what work about the night of the
doctor was it Steven Moffat who had
thought about it actually reconciled a
few of the gaps that playing Lee that
you know fans had got exercised about
you know with the war and the things
made sense in a way the mythology writes
itself
though the scripts don't so if I did
come back it would be just too frightful
it would have to be to fulfill you know
a function otherwise it'd be just a
novelty thing you know okay look three
doctors do this or you know I'd much I'd
be more interested I think in you know
coming back and having us serious it can
be over serious but like I did in light
of the doctor you know where there's a
you've got people look at the story and
go oh I see I get it now this fits in
with this and um you know so it means
something
I enjoyed that I enjoyed that aspect of
it what's a really fantastic bit of
writing a Moffat
you know to have just in six or seven
minutes to have managed to to do what he
did you know and even you know if
there's all this info in you know I say
answer a few old questions posed a few
new ones introduce some of you from the
70s and John hurt again I can go get a
regeneration in you know spring a
complete surprise and all in six minutes
and even in the middle have a bit of
boredom in the middle we now she pulled
that off in five minutes
really clever did he think when you got
the script for that well I had to agree
to it when I'm in the it was conditional
on on my seeing the script on the idea
of it but the problem wasn't Stephen
hadn't written anything because he first
contacted me to say look would you on
principle do it because if you say yes
I'll do it then I'll write it if you
don't then like I've got no time you see
because otherwise because they were
trying to get the big 50th thing after
that so so I said yes then go ahead and
he sent me little bits
I could see instantly it you know but we
did but we didn't see I didn't see them
what would be the definitive thing
probably until a few days before we did
it and even then it changed I could be
wrong but I got the impression that he
probably were finalized it the day
before we did it
and if that's the case then he probably
should do more eleventh-hour work
because it obviously suits him
it was brilliant you know
and it worked we spoke to a lot of fans
and the 50th anniversary celebrations
last year and they were all really
really keen on you coming back as a
doctor I mean even if that was in a kind
of spin off series of your own what do
you think of that idea
I think it's wishful thinking you know
but then that's what this is all about
wishful thinking you know I think this
mean the reality is again you know
Capaldi's the reality pizzas you know
doing this thing and we're into the
modern era with it I don't see yet if at
all practically that there's a chance
that any of us McCoy or Colin or anybody
should has a right to expect that we'll
come back and be included obviously your
anniversaries come up in this you know
that there are specials but I don't see
why it should happen really unless the
unless the story itself you know in the
ongoing mythology of itself deserves it
so I'm not expecting anything I'm but
doesn't stop people doesn't have people
wishing there's not you're dreaming
personally I have no ambitions
whatsoever but only in this in the
spirit that whatever happens happens you
know I don't I don't crave to do it
because that you know you work long
enough as an actor and you know that
that's foolish you know if only why
can't I know you drive yourself mad just
just whatever is down for you will
happen whatever whatever comes along
will happen
how much did you know about who else is
taking part in those 15 anniversary
specials before
well I knew about the parvis doctors
because you know I was with them we were
in Australia you know for the preceding
year we'd known of course about the big
anniversary and also Peter Davison said
to us you know I'm going to be trying to
do this thing
but but that in itself snowballs it
wasn't a BBC thing to start with it was
an independent thing piece of done it
before so we was able to say to us
personally well if you know but do it
when you get involved we all said yes
and then I took off and then the BBC got
very interesting they decided yeah then
it became under their aegis you know
which is great I thought that was
actually the best thing of the whole of
the whole weekend and that that had to
me that had the spirit you know of the
thing and I know people fans have said
the same thing so would mind doing one
of those again and Zoku she mentioned
Peter Capaldi the new doctor and
everyone's really looking forward to
seeing him get into the material I think
on-screen can be something different
isn't he what do you think he's going to
bring to that role and and why do you
think he's such a good choice
I think he's a great choice Peter well
few simple reasons he looks great and I
know we know we know now even the other
day of Steven Moffat went into the press
again saying you know just expressing
his own preference his own ideas about
what the doctor should look like and
sound like everything else and for him
Capaldi is the perfect example of how he
thinks the doctor should look so great
Peter's of great shows were because he's
a fantastic actor you know his versatile
he's been there he's done it
you know he's singing not impressed by
you know either the pressure or the
glamour you know the challenge of things
he's also hugely intelligent man anyway
Peter brilliantly talented but that you
know diversely talented which helps when
he has this gift
he's not the only intelligent actor out
there but he's one of them is one of the
actors that is able to play it and
sometimes you get very bright actors
that can't play bright just one of those
things Peter can you can play funny and
bright you know in the you know in the
same breath and even what I like about
him as we've seen with his Malcolm
Tucker thing he can be funny and scary
at the same time so you see what I mean
everything in a way that the doctor as
we know him she naturally [ __ ] her or
represent you know so he's got that
weirdness and he's got that strength and
he's got a boyish thing and I Moffat
says of course he has you know he's has
got this lovely thing about I think when
I said it before he stands a chance of
being the best end up if they give him
time and the material you know I think
people history will judge obviously but
I think in time we'll see people got oh
my god yes that's how it should be you
know and it will get better and better
and better
I really do I really that's just cuz I'm
that's not just cuz I knowin you know I
do and I really admire him but I think
he's a great choice you know what my
choice I would have I would have thought
it might have been a chance to get a
female doctor
but there weren't many of us saying that
I mean I know she's never done it but
can you imagine you imagine Tilda
Swinton playing the doctor you know
someone like that you know what I mean
somebody but then Peter has some of
those elements anyway she's another one
you know fantastically bright but can
play it weird like an alien you know so
Tully yeah would have been great but
Lily yeah I think if you could bring
your own doctor and the new Peter Paola
doctor together on screen what would you
make a fad what you mean if we were both
included well the thing is if you have
two doctors there are they are the same
person
what kind of hampers the drama slightly
when it's hello me oh hello you me no
it's interesting for a while but after a
while it isn't I don't think no I think
you should have one doctor but that's
just me I'm pointing slightly
old-fashioned than that we're going
who would sing I'll see what Peters got
to do and I know as in all the Doctor
Who fans we would love to see you back
as well so hopefully at some point we
will see you for another five minutes or
many many more 17 years from now that
was the gap between the two world will
be orbit and we'll all be had but I'll
have a free bus pass but only but you
know you never know
you